♫ ♫
>> Laura: WE ARE IN
NEW ORLEANS TONIGHT, THE CITY AT
THE HEART OF THE BATTLE OVER
PRESERVING AMERICAN HISTORY AND
CONFEDERATE MONUMENTS.
NEW ORLEANS HAS THE WORST MURDER
RATE, EVEN WORSE THAN CHICAGO
TODAY, , AND MORE SHOOTINGS PER
CAPITA THAN BALTIMORE, IF YOU
CAN BELIEVE IT.
AND MAYOR MITCH LANDRIEU IS ON A
CRUSADE, NOT NECESSARILY TO STOP
CRIME, BUT TO HIDE HISTORY.
>> THESE MONUMENTS CELEBRATE A
FICTIONAL, SANITIZED
CONFEDERACY, IGNORING THE DEATH,
IGNORING THE ENSLAVEMENT,
IGNORING THE TERROR THAT IT
ACTUALLY STOOD FOR, AND AFTER
THE CIVIL WAR, THESE MONUMENTS
WERE PART OF THAT TERRORISM.
AS MUCH AS BURNING A CROSS ON
SOMEONE’S LAWN.
THEY WERE ERECTED PURPOSELY TO
SEND A STRONG MESSAGE TO ALL WHO
WALKED IN THE SHADOWS ABOUT WHO
WAS STILL IN CHARGE IN THIS
CITY.
>> Laura: NEW ORLEANS TOOK
DOWN FOUR CONFEDERATE STATUES
LAST MAY AFTER THE CITY COUNCIL
DECLARED THEM IN A PUBLIC
NUISANCE.
THERE WAS NO VOTE OF THE PEOPLE.
LANDRIEU CALLED THE EFFORT A
MOVE TOWARD HEALING.
LET’S DISCUSS STATUES, THE
MAYOR’S PRIORITIES, AND WHAT IS
NEXT WITH THE COORDINATOR WITH
THE GROUP CALLED "TAKE ’EM DOWN
NOLA" AND THE LEADER OF THE
ROBERT ELITE MONUMENT
ASSOCIATION.
MALCOLM, LET’S START WITH YOU.
YOU MUST BE PRETTY HAPPY THAT
YOU TOOK DOWN FOUR STATUES, GOT
JEFF DAVIS DOWN, ROBERT E. LEE,
GOT THAT LIBERTY MONUMENTS DOWN,
AND GENERAL BEAUREGARD, GOT FOUR
STATUES DOWN, WHAT’S NEXT FOR
YOU?
>> WELL, OUR NAME IS TAKE ’EM
DOWN NOLA, AND WE WANT TO TAKE
THEM ALL DOWN.
THERE ARE 20 MORE STATUES THAT
ARE DEDICATED TO WHITE SUPREMACY
IN THE CITY OF NEW ORLEANS.
WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF STREETS
NAMED AND PARKS NAMED FOR
CONFEDERATE AND WHITE
SUPREMACISTS, AND WE WANT TO
WIPE THE SLATE CLEAN, AND WE
HAVE CHALLENGED THE MAYOR, FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING, DON’T DO A
HALF JOB, LET’S DO THE WHOLE
JOB.
>> Laura: MALCOLM, I WANT TO
JUMP IN HERE, BECAUSE JACKSON
SQUARE, THAT IS NEW ORLEANS,
JACKSON SQUARE, DO YOU SAY THAT
JACKSON SQUARE -- JACKSON SQUARE
IS NOT NEW ORLEANS?
>> NO, IT’S NOT NEW ORLEANS.
DO YOU WANT ANDREW JACKSON TO
BE >> Laura: DO YOU WANT
ANDREW JACKSON TO BE
ERADICATED -- OKAY, LET’S MOVE
ON.
WOULD YOU LIKE THOMAS JEFFERSON,
ANYTHING RELATED TO
THOMAS JEFFERSON --
THOMAS JEFFERSON HAS TO GO?
GEORGE WASHINGTON HAS TO GO?
WHO ELSE IS LEFT?
IS MADISON OKAY?
JAMES MADISON OKAY WITH YOU?
>> NO, HE IS NOT OKAY.
HE WAS A SLAVE OWNER.
HE IS NOT.
>> Laura: OKAY.
SO WE NEED TO RENAME
WASHINGTON, D.C., CORRECT?
>> YES, I WOULD DO THAT.
>> Laura: OKAY, RENAME
WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> THAT’S NOT FOR ME TO
DETERMINE.
>> Laura: NO, WE NEED TO KNOW,
MALCOLM, WHERE YOU ARE COMING
FROM.
AND WE JUST ESTABLISHED IT,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET’S MOVE ON TO THOMAS, THOMAS,
TIME FOR YOU TO TALK ON.
WHITE SUPREMACY, WE GOT IT.
THOMAS, WHAT IS YOUR SENSE ON
THIS?
>> WELL, LAURA, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME, FIRST OF ALL.
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY, I LOVE THE
FACT THAT MALCOLM WANTS TO ALLOW
WASHINGTON, D.C., TO VOTE ON THE
NAME OF THE CAPITAL.
WHY DIDN’T HE ALLOW US TO HAVE A
VOTE IN NEW ORLEANS ON THE
REMOVAL OF THE MONUMENTS?
THE MAYOR, THE CITY COUNCIL HAS
DECIDED FOR THEMSELVES ON THIS
ISSUE --
>> Laura: LET HIM SPEAK PLEASE
COME UP MALCOLM.
MALCOLM.
MALCOLM, MY FRIEND.
YOU MUST LET THE OTHER GUEST
SPEAKER.
IT IS RUDE.
PLEASE LET THOMAS SPEAK.
THANK YOU.
>> OKAY, SO MALCOLM SAID THAT
THESE STATUES REPRESENT WHITE
SUPREMACY.
I’M NOT IN A POSITION TO TELL
MALCOLM WHAT HE SHOULD THINK
ABOUT THESE STATUES.
THESE ARE PIECES OF ART.
FOLKS ARE FREE TO MAKE THEIR OWN
INTERPRETATION OF WHAT THEY MEAN
OR DON’T MEAN.
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
WAYS OF LOOKING AT THESE PIECES.
FOR HIM TO SAY THAT THESE ARE
THIS WAY AND THAT ANYONE WHO
DISAGREES WITH THAT IS WRONG, TO
ME, IT’S ABSURD.
THESE ARE PIECES OF ART, THEY
ARE CREATED IN A MANNER IN WHICH
THERE ARE A MULTIPLICITY OF WAYS
OF LOOKING AT THEM, AND WHEN
THEY LOOK AT THESE PIECES OF
ART, THEY HAVE A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT WAYS OF INTERPRETING
THEM.
I HAVE BEEN AROUND THESE PIECES
OF ART ALL OF MY LIFE, AND IT
NEVER OCCURRED TO ME FOR ONE
SECOND THAT THEY WERE PIECES OF
WHITE SUPREMACY.
IN FACT, MITCH LANDRIEU WROTE
HIMSELF SAID, WHEN HE WAS
CHALLENGED TO TAKE DOWN THE
STATUES, MITCH SAID, WHAT ARE
YOU TALKING ABOUT?
I DON’T KNOW WHAT YOU MEAN.
STATUES MEAN WHITE SUPREMACY?
THE REASON THAT MITCH DID NOT
UNDERSTAND THAT, A LOT OF FOLKS
IN THIS CITY DO NOT SEE THE
STATUES THAT WAY.
>> Laura: LET’S GO BACK TO
MALCOLM.
MALCOLM, MALCOLM, HOLD ON.
MALCOLM --
>> WHEN THESE STATUES --
>> Laura: MALCOLM, UNTIL THE
LAST, I DON’T KNOW, TWO, THREE
YEARS -- I’VE COME TO
NEW ORLEANS ON AND OFF FOR THE
LAST TWO OR THREE YEARS.
UNTIL THE LAST, ABOUT TWO YEARS,